ready for a little relationship advice
let's help people do what we do best
isn't it I think so maybe you're right
actually bro we're doing all right with
uh from Aden this is from Aden from
Georgia
another Moby Oh what's good Brandon the
gang gang buzz-buzz
relationship advice I was into this girl
mm-hmm I found out I was a lesbian and
it kind of sucked typically didn't work
out and then ever since then every girl
I went into I find out they're a lesbian
like no matter what I didn't even know
how that many lesbians existed but I'm
an art student you know these girls are
like not kind of butch but you know
weird hair colors we're clothing maybe
experimental socialism I guess my type
yeah ever since Denison lesbians left or
right and I don't know II do man help me
break this curse I see what's going on
here lesbian soda laughs listen quit
hitting on girls with the same haircut
as Theo that's your problem the other
thing is do you think that maybe they're
lying teak is just not into you if it
keeps happening they might be lying dude
they don't hurt your feelings look man
here's marking up the wrong tree
a lot of lesbianism out there these days
and a lot of women that don't even know
if there are lesbians that have just
been you know listen in a Chelsea
Handler too much so you got a lot of
like misplaced you know sexual identity
going on so hot to be gay right now yeah
and it sells so it's also hot to just be
an angry lady who doesn't ever use her
vagina for any drinking on Twitter and
they don't have wind or to have children
right
just to like accuse people of crimes
within it that happened inside of it but
I'm saying this brother if you're at an
art school dude look if a lady has more
than if she doesn't want a paint in her
backpack dude she probably led me in
broth dude if she's rolling her jeans up
and she has some Doc Martens on and
black [ __ ] nail polish is he sucking
tits this is easy to figure it out bro
bro there's no Sherlock Holmes situation
yeah analyze what's going on there's
some Kinkos with a couple of [ __ ]
with more than one key chain on it dawg
no dude if she has a green
sure probably sucking tits bro yeah if
she sees you with a hot chick and
[ __ ] goes like this no does that do
it someday a lot of those women are
angry man a lot I'm more angry and so I
think but if you're taking a girl to a
date and she like um how do you know if
a girl's a Leslie when you take her out
what do you guys think if she offers to
change the tire and pay for the meal and
do everything that dude and [ __ ] you
afternoon the meal probably that might
be right that might be wifey though my
wifey for some that sounds horrible to
have him to [ __ ] on a full stomach
how you doing for a pasta dinner and
then I get a [ __ ] oh my girl bro I'll
[ __ ] on a Saturday morning and that's it
empty empty stomach after a run catch me
the next life yeah I'm that
reincarnation Connie you can catch me
next time don't feed me a whole cheese
pizza and expect me to lay it down yeah
slap it like Derek know what happening
don't feed me a cheese pizza and call me
big Randy you know what I'm saying
yeah don't be me a footlong sub and
expect my footlong it ain't happen bro I
got a full stomach you feel me yeah
barely feel yeah let's go what were you
gonna say Ken how do you know if she
sucks [ __ ] or not well first of all we
don't say [ __ ] on here what do we say
huh
what she already said tits and that was
good pal got it tits were good all right
why I want to emphasize the cat people
know it's hot it's hard to tell whatever
they want
hot girl summer I got a romp run mm-hmm
maybe you should hook up with a lesbian
chick and see if she goes straight
afterwards you know I can't though I
think he keeps taking women out he's
basically lesbians they're not like gay
dudes like they're not even gonna [ __ ]
with a dick dude girl you take out is
just a lesbian you're at the it sounds
like you might just be um which one of
the people that shows you around school
with the beginning of school when you
get there an RA no it's um it's kind of
like that but it's like remember you
come to school a few days early and they
show you around yeah you might just be
or do work for the orientation sounds
like yeah you new to camp
what's going on you think you're trying
to [ __ ] everybody they're just not into
it and dude if you're taking a lesbian
out brah you need to also you I would
get a female wig on i-i'll try and run
the threesome game you know I'm saying
he can't get a one some dude
yeah but she's into other girls you like
do let's toss some guy oh that's a good
idea
that's a [ __ ] in the wrench no she's a
bear else I know but why not have him in
there but I think if you're a guy and a
girl won't look up with you you can't be
like hey not only don't hook up with me
don't hook up with me and my buddy it's
a tough game dude
welcome you know what I like this guy he
likes a challenge yeah thank you and ha
mission impossible as I call it right
you've been drinking diesel out of some
of them food trucks they're you know
[ __ ] yeah you might know dude strikes
again you might be right dude the only
reason I started this show cuz I thought
deal was a lesbian and so hot right now
I find out he's not hot girls yeah
whatever dude I'm in the chicks bro with
the tits boy - tit hey whatever bro ya
know we all believe that I'm into those
double Ted chicks boy find me around
some teat ties boy and some cooter son
like a champion no failure this guy
wishes he could get there good luck man
quit hollering that lesbians though you
feel me yeah you'll be fine dude what's
your problem dude you're playing
baseball everyone else playing football
switch it up bro you're the wrong game
yeah I think if you're only catching
lesbians you got to change your bait you
know yeah yeah maybe it's the way you
dress dude yeah maybe wear some maybe
wear like a football t-shirt or
something or a jersey you let them know
you're a straight heterosexual man yes
right now you might be some mixed
signals but so you might have a romper
on yeah put some elk on put a little bit
elk on you know spray a little elk
[ __ ] [ __ ] on your neck yeah your beef
jerky and just [ __ ] put it behind the
ears a little bit so these [ __ ] know
you smell like Slim Jim
yeah drove a little bit of here pick a
deer piss on a Becky a bald head yeah
no I'm saying show your work boy don't
just get to the answer show you work
take a little gravy put it on your
[ __ ] tits dude I love that man that's
me you're making stuff up are you right
too much what else we gotta do you guys
gonna rip a little trip
yeah we'll rip some Kizer has that all
we been doing I feel like all we do is
just make fun of people and then go home
I feel like I feel like we make fun of
each other and everyone else pretty safe
I feel like we help that guy out he's
gonna get his wardroom like you know
what I am dressing like a lesbian what
else you got
dude I'll tell you this you're yeah and
if the allows me ins keep coming at you
boy then you know I'll tuck your dick
fight him bro no dude don't fight him
tuck your dick bro though sometimes you
gotta be gonna hit a [ __ ] of the body
my buddy got beat up by two lesbians
dude last month that are armed outside
of a crystal burger well he probably
deserved it dude no he didn't why what'd
he do well he didn't do anything he was
looking for something outside of his car
he dropped something and they just beat
him up yeah those lesbians are rough to
do switch for the butch kind you got to
hit a [ __ ] to the body liver shot don't
hit him the face yeah go with those
liver shots boy yeah good cause that's
important liver shot before you a dude
in two rounds son gonna beat that ass
and go back to the hotel early breath I
hope you're right
[Music]
King nothing
[Music]